all right so a rollercoaster of a week I
guess is a really good way to describe
off seven days yeah what happened
well I mean everybody was telling me all
week that they were gunning for Johnny
to go hmm which was the smart game move
he wins all the competitions and he has
good social connections with everybody
in the house and apparently somehow I
was the bigger threat I guess
well I Mathias so you were up on the
Block four times four times in a row so
what's the difference between the first
timer up and like the fourth timing up
like how does that change your mental
state the way you play the game the
first time you're on the block I mean
the first time I hit the block it was
during the double eviction so it was so
quick and I won the veto and took myself
down so I didn't really have time to
process everything that was going on but
the the first kind of full week that
you're on the block
I you're making your pitch you're saying
okay well this is why you should keep me
and this is why I'm an advantage to your
game long-term and this is why I should
stay in the house by the time you've
been doing that for 15 or 18 straight
days and you're trying to again tell
people why they should keep you in the
house when they were going to send you
home and Canada kept you there by then
the conversations aren't new they're not
fresh there's no new approach because
the angle I had always taken was the
angle I thought works best for that
particular person yeah and so it's it's
hard to keep selling yourself when
people already aren't buying right is
there anything you would have that you
would have done differently I mean
there's so many things you want to do
differently and throughout I think
winning the week winning the HOH in week
2 because of how I wanted to play the
game ended up backfiring on me I should
have tried to throw it and let will have
the HOH early because you know Andrew
would have gone home and and still in
the that nothing would have changed from
a result standpoint that week but it
wouldn't have been my fault and I
wouldn't have been gathering the
information I tried to get and and
really put myself in an untenable
position over the course of the week did
you find yourself going over through
things that you've done in the house
ways that you've played the game and
thinking are
and this I couldn't all right or is it
just kind of like it's a dead exercise I
said the expression if ifs and buts were
candy and nuts we'd all have a Merry
Christmas you can't you can't live in
the past you need to keep moving forward
and and only look at what you can do
because you can't fix what you've
already done you can only do it right
the next time and so I tried to take
that approach with some people but it
just was too late let's talk about the
moment you know just a moment it
happened was it a shock to you and also
do you think and I'm sure that you do
but do you think that they made the
wrong decision like it's a hundred
percent the wrong game you know you had
Johnny on the block on Thursday what do
they have now with Johnny left in the
house like what kind of animal is a
candidate they've got a guy who can win
em they've got a guy who could win out
there would be it would not surprise me
to see Johnny winning one of the two
major competitions the rest of the way
and be sitting on finale night a
unanimous winner because everybody would
have to respect how he got there Johnny
is an incredibly smart player an
incredibly well-connected socially
player and somebody who can win
competitions when he wants to and all
three of those things combined means
that they really missed an opportunity
to a victim they got rid of Erica last
week who was very similar they should
have done the same this week and I would
have said that whether I was on the
block or not Johnny was a far more
threatening person - everybody's
long-term game than I was yeah
so now that you are first in Missouri
yes right who do you see making it
through to the end well I'd like to see
Johnny sitting next to Paris for
sentimental reasons yeah I really the
relationship I built with Paris was very
kind of a father-daughter type thing and
and you know I want to see her go deep
in the game because I love her as a
person and I really want her to go deep
I just everybody else's game plays is
that a shallow level compared to
Johnny's that from a superfan
perspective like I have if Johnny's not
I see Johnny walking into the jury house
I'll be very disappointed and I know
that finale night won't be nearly as
much fun for me as it could be
is there anyone that you just want to
see go down in flames at this point well
obviously I want to see Kayla go down in
flames but at the same time send her out
like final four or final three so I
don't have to live with her anymore
that's that's kind of where I want to be
I don't want her to have any kind of
actual success in the game yeah but I'm
also not interested in seeing her in the
jury house either so I'd like to see her
kind of get to that four or three level
where she doesn't win and she doesn't
make any money for getting to the finals
but still I don't have to spend any time
with her yeah tell me how I really feel
well you know I I would but this is TV
[Laughter]